und dennoch wird natürlich auch in
russland gegen putins blutigen krieg
demonstriert und das erfordert dort sehr
viel mut zum beispiel für diese
kunstaktion in moskau ein anonymer
künstler stellt dort die gräueltaten von
butscher nach die protest kunst wird
über telegramm und andere soziale
netzwerke verbreitet und kaum sind diese
szenen im kasten ist er auch schon
wieder verschwunden
und wir schauen hier nach berlin
sonntagnachmittag 400 fahrzeuge 900
menschen die russische fahne schwenken
darunter auch flaggen mit putins creek
symbol menschen singen die hymne den
blumen an so wird denkmal in berlin ab
und zu solidarisieren sich mit russland
und das genau an dem tag an welchen die
grausamen bilder ausputzer die welt
erschüttern bilder der kriegsverbrechen
von creme diktator putin tote zivilisten
ermordet hingerichtet auf offener straße
es ist der autokorso der schande
organisiert von diesem mann christian f
41 jähriger mann aus mahlsdorf in berlin
christian f soll sich auch ein
davidstern auf sein auto geklebt haben
darauf die frage bald auch wir die
polizei forderte ihn auf diesen zu
entfernen und vor wenigen minuten stellt
unser reporter christian f exklusiv vor
seinem betrieb in berlin einer der
mitorganisatoren der demo äußert sich
exklusiv bei uns hier bei bild und er
rechtfertigt putins einmarsch in die
ukraine
der don was ist ein eigenständiges
gebiet und die wollen eigenständig leben
dann lasst sie unter russischen statuten
leben seit 2014 haben die leute in der
ost ukraine krieg da wurden die leute
abgeschlachtet und wenn der russe kommt
und sagt wir helfen weil die menschen es
verlangt haben dann heißt es er sei
einmarschiert
das wirft natürlich die frage auf wer
sind die russen in deutschland leben und
sich dennoch mit putin solidarisieren
wie viel einfluss hat putin auf
russlanddeutsche darüber wollen wir
jetzt sprechen mit schriftsteller
vladimir kaminer er selbst ist in moskau
geboren lebt heute in deutschland und
mails zugeschaltet herr kaminer schön
dass sie bei uns sind was ging ihnen
durch das herz was ging ihnen durch den
kopf als sie die bilder dieses auto
korso gesehen haben
also ziemlich sarah dieser autokorso
ganz eindeutig nach eine provokation
eine privatperson
neben
einer demo anhat dann ganz schnell 900
freunde die fast alle über 2 x 2 größe
russische pannen und verfügen und sie
fahren gerade an dem tag durch die
straßen von berlin als die schrecklichen
bilder von von umgebrachten zivilisten
dann um die welt geht unter
ich glaube auf einer seite
macht dieses video einen guten content
für russische propaganda medien ja gut
und gern als opfer dargestellt auf der
anderen seite verunsichert natürlich ein
solches bild die russischsprachige
bevölkerung in deutschland
also ich sehe das als eine provokation
ganz stecken da steckt mehr dahinter als
eine privatperson
man fragt sich das sind 900 mensch man
fragt sich wer sind diese menschen haben
sie eine antwort darauf wer das sein
könnte 900 menschen wir haben wenige
autokennzeichen die dazu erklären sie
sieht man dass das
menschen aus ganz deutschland sein
sollen aus
niederbergischen
nordrhein westfalen auf allen möglichen
ecken sie müssen 500 kilometer gefahren
sein nach berlin und ich möcht ich
möchte ich dir auch glückliche sagen
dass die meisten mönche sprachigen hier
ukrainisch und geflüchtet und kämpfen
und natürlich auch für europa
für den frieden und gegen pudding und
seine geschrieben sind
es gibt es gibt sicher auf provokateure
wir wissen von einer russischen schule
die angezündet wird die aus seiner
eine einigkeit gleich große geschichte
machen es gibt keine rose vor wien werde
in berlin noch in deutschland oder in
europa
es gibt ein ihm fehle das wirklich
meinen freund hat mir jetzt erzählt sein
seine tochter erste klasse grundschule
musste weinen als der lehrer die klasse
fragte zu werden seither gehen dafür
ukraine oder für russland alle waren zu
klein hat und nur das kleine mädchen war
zur russland und fühlte sich natürlich
vorteil der total blöd dann haben die
eltern mit der direktorin der schule
gesprochen die direktorin hat mit diesem
lehrer der kurz vor ende steht dann
gesprochen er meint es nicht so aus
solchen kleinigkeiten entstehen dann für
große ängste phobien und die werden
ausgeschlachtet durch russische
staatsfernsehen jungs propaganda
soweit könnte also auch der propaganda
erreichen das sind bilder über die man
sich dann natürlich ja von
propagandistischer seite her freut dass
auch die befürchtung von vladimir
kaminer angesichts des autokorso hier in
berlin am wochenende vielen herzlichen
dank für ihre einschätzungen zu diesem
thema